hey what's up guys my name is china
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time
we did some frame buffer stuff to do
with our mouse picking journey check out
that video up there if you haven't
already
and basically today what we're going to
focus on is two things i want to talk a
little bit about our general kind of get
strategy for
hazel and for this like game engine
series version of hazel because we're
going to start creating branches and
various other things as we get into
more complex features and then the other
thing i want to do today is deal with
our clear color because
basically what we did last time um i'll
show you a few things actually what we
did last time was
inside our um fragment shader we were
now able to with our new texture
attachment
inside our frame buffer we were able to
output an integer
and in this case we just arbitrarily
chose to output 50
into that actual texture so that we
could eventually
store our entity ids for every pixel
that we actually render
now the problem with this at the moment
is that if we load up a scene
like this pink cube for example uh
when we're over the pink cube right you
can see that
it is in fact 50. but for all of the
pixels that are just
in empty space it's this weird value
the reason is this weird value is
because if we're not deliberately
actually like
rendering a pixel into that spot in our
texture
then it's going to be set to the clear
color because that's what
that's what we do first we clear the
whole screen with a particular value
essentially with a particular
clear color and then pixels go pixels
that we actually rasterize go on top of
that
well they get overwritten with the new
values of whatever pixel we've just
rendered
so again it's fine for when we're over
this but if we're over this kind of
empty space
we don't want it to be this which is i
mean presumably whatever our clear color
is and if we go back to editor layout
we can see that at the moment we're
using this little render um render
command set clear color
function to set it to like 0.1 0.1 0.1
and then one
for the alpha this is clearly great for
our rgba kind of main color buffer
but not so much for our integer buffer
that is supposed to store the entity id
instead we'd like it to be negative one
so basically what we need to do
is clear the second color attachment so
we have two color attachments zero and
one
zero is the main rgba buffer and then
one is that kind of
gl red integer buffer and again if you
don't know what i'm talking about check
out the previous episode
um we need to clear that to negative one
and that's what we're going to do today
so we're going to learn about clearing
individual
frame buffer attachments instead of
everything which is what gel clear
will do but first let's take a little
bit of a look
at uh fork actually so fork is a get
client that i really like and that i use
um this applies to any get client out
there
i just happen to like fork now we have a
whole bunch of stuff here that i haven't
actually committed right so this was the
last commit
on the 23rd of january which was like
updated editor layer with frame buffer
api changes and
uh well no actually it was this one that
was just a little extra commit because i
forgot to commit to commit like an
important
part of everything but anyway so you can
see that all the changes um
that we added were kind of just to do
with the new
frame buffer api but now we have
something
that kind of uh i guess puts me on a
little bit of a crossroads because
we have a whole bunch of changes here
that change the way that hazel works but
it's not necessarily keeping it stable
in a way right so as we embark on this
um
journey of like mouse picking you know
we wind up with
uh you know in this case a version of
hazel that has
an extra an extra like texture
attachment
inside the frame buffer that outputs the
value 50 prints it to the console
and i mean doesn't add any value to
anything because it's more mouse picking
isn't done yet so
in this situation what do we do and this
again this might be like a little bit of
a primitive episode for a lot of you who
are
building game engines and know how git
works but don't forget this series is
for everyone
so i will cover things like this from
time to time so
instead of basically um you know keeping
everything in the master branch which
basically means that we have this master
uh branch it is like our kind of main
uh well at the moment it's the only kind
of flow
of the repository i guess every time we
commit something we basically take a
snapshot of
our entire code base and any files we
have at that point in time
uh and we can kind of scroll through and
revert back to anything we want and see
what
what changes every single time but what
if we want like
an another copy of that somewhat
temporarily
right i mean maybe we'll keep it forever
maybe we won't but we want to basically
divert from the
kind of main point of the code base so
that people can still access this commit
which is which works and which kind of
you know has the main let's just say
hazel example
but then we also want to kind of branch
off of that and commit in our own kind
of uh
you know track of code or whatever
as we develop new features that might
not might not necessarily be done yet
and might not be stable enough
for for them to actually be mainline or
part of the master branch so what we can
do there
is just create a new branch basically
and again this isn't like a little git
tutorial but
for those of you who are unaware of why
i'm doing this basically what i'm going
to do is
while we do this mouse picking stuff
until it's fully done
it's going to be on a separate branch
which i'll call mouse picking
and then once that is done it's going to
be merged back into master so if you're
watching this series and you're
wondering where the code from this
episode will be
it's not going to be on the master
branch it's going to be on a different
branch and i'll actually show you how
all of that works as well so in fork we
can we can still go ahead and like stage
everything
but um what you can do with branches is
just create a new branch i'll call it
mouse picking
um and then now i'm well i can check out
the
mouse picking branch right i'm not going
to change my local changes at all
right now i'm here and then when i go
ahead and commit everything now it's
going to be committed into the mouse
picking branch which has branched off
of master at the at the commit that i
was currently at which happens to be the
latest commit
if people commit in the meantime to
master and those branches are now
different then
you'll have to merge but otherwise it
should be pretty straightforward
let's stage all of our changes uh now we
have
so this is actually from last episode
all these changes
i think i just cleaned up a little bit
of the formatting here to make it look
nicer and yeah so that looks pretty good
so what were the actual changes
so we added um geo red integer basically
as a format
add a gl red integer as a frame buffer
format plus uh
uh test plus test
whatever so i'll come in and push that
so now you can see if we go back to all
commits we're on the mouse picking
branch and we've got this stuff here
so i've pushed that as well and i did
that on purpose so that i could
show you guys who uh want to actually
view that code of that particular branch
if you go to the hazel github
which is um github.comhazel you can just
go to hazelengine.com it'll take you
here
you can see that we have this master
branch but then we also have
mouse picking so you actually have to
click on mouse picking and then you can
view the code of what i just committed
right and obviously if you want to clone
it you can
you can go ahead and like uh you know
clone the whole repository first and
then
do like get checkout mouse picking to
check out the mouse picking branch you
can clone
the um or you can pull you can probably
clone at yeah you can clone and or pull
the mouse picking branch immediately but
just by going like get clone like you do
here
um git clone rehearse recursive but just
add a little dash b
and then mouse picking and then that
will immediately clone the right branch
for you sometimes that's useful because
branches
can be well completely different one
branch might be 10 gigabytes
one branch might be one gigabyte so you
might want to immediately get the branch
you're after so you're not just cloning
stuff for no reason waiting around
thank you wolf by the way will frick for
your uh subscription
so anyway that's the basic idea we're
gonna be on this mouse picking branch
a little bit of backstory as to why we
like to do stuff like that
um but uh we'll be doing a lot more of
this in the future just because
uh obviously we'll we'll want to leave
we basically want to leave master in a
decent place so that people who just
want to check out hazel and seed
actually work
will be able to do so without having
random stuff show up in their console
and
potentially you know experience hazel in
a broken state
which is now something we can do here we
could we could even make a commit here
that just doesn't even compile i mean
probably wouldn't recommend that
unless you're doing it for a reason but
you could just commit here
and not even have it compiled because
you have the master branch that is
stable and then this is like a
development branch
and anything goes there okay i think
that was probably a
little bit of a long-winded explanation
there but hopefully uh everyone is on
the same page now
okay so how do we clear this thing how
do we even clear a particular
frame buffer um texture attachment well
there's a function that we need to run
essentially called gel clear text image
that allows us to clear an actual
texture
with a value right so um
as always there's this really nice side
i think i've mentioned this before
but it's a really nice little
documentation site for opengl called
docs gl
um even has a dark theme that is
sometimes annoying because i think when
you load a page it
goes to white first and then flips to
like that
so it's like a little flash so i don't
really like that about it but aside from
that it's a great little site
keep it on light you can type in a
function here and um
check it out so it feels all fills all a
texture image with a constant value
that's a great explanation so far
feels all an image contained
all right whatever anyway the point is
that this um
this fills a particular image with a
particular value that is inside a
texture
so you can specify the texture the level
um uh
level of attachment region filled the
format um
the type and the data right so the idea
is that we should be able to use that
with specifically the first color
attachment because
as you um recall we obviously created
two textures here
one ended up being an rgba which was
color attachment zero technically
and we specified all of this in our
frame buffer specifications over here we
have
rgba and red integer so for the red
integer which happens to be color
index one or sorry texture attachment
index one color color attachment index
one really
um we uh we
uh want to clear that with negative one
specifically just that one
and furthermore it's important that we
do this after
we run clear so when we have
our render command clear over here that
will actually clear all of the
attachments in the frame buffer to this
clear color
that's what gel clear does we want to
after we clear that we basically need to
clear
our entity id attachment we'll call it
two negative one
that's our goal for today so how do we
do that and how do we develop an api for
that
so again the function that we need to
run sometimes it helps to write this
down so let's go to frame buffer
binds and then what i'm going to do
is uh call that function gl clear
uh text image right geo text uh gluing
texture is the first
uh parameter so that's actually going to
be the texture id now we have a list of
all the ids here in color attachments so
we know that it's going to be one
this should maybe be something that we
parameterize though next
um is the level zero that's like the mip
um
format will be uh well in this case gel
red integer the internal format type is
int
because that's what that's the type of i
think that's the type of data that we
clear with
so if i bring back our documentation the
type of data whose address is given by
data right so this is not
necessarily the type of data inside the
texture it's the type of data that
you're providing with this
right so um it'll be an int and we want
to basically pass in negative one so
we're going to have a value of negative
one
and then we'll pass in the memory
address of value and
that's our function if we run this right
now it should actually clear everything
to negative one now the problem is that
we want to obviously make this a little
bit more modular so how do we deal
with that
[Music]
okay so to do that let's go back to
frame buffer and define an api for this
so
how do i even come up with an api for
this well
clear text image i mean
like the name itself is decent right um
we could say
clear attachment clear texture
attachment or something like that it's
clear that attachments are textures they
could be render buffers but
we won't worry about that for now we
could call it clear attachment
we could pass in an index for the
attachment
so this won't be a renderer id this will
just be like zero or one or two
depending on
which one you actually want to clear um
probably should mention that it's the
color attachment
so maybe we could call a clear color
color attachment maybe it doesn't matter
i don't know
i don't really care about the level i
don't think we'll ever parameterize that
and then the format also the format we
can actually tell from this color
attachment thing
because aside from keeping color
attachments we also have color
attachment specifications
which line up with these and those
specifications
of course contain the actual frame
buffer texture format
so we don't need this now this
could be useful right how do we specify
that it's an
int well
again this this is this is where it gets
a little bit more complicated
so we could assume that if it's gl red
integer
you're going to be giving it an int
whereas if it's a
gl rgba you're giving it maybe a float
right we could actually imply that um
and that might be the best way to go
and then finally the value we can leave
it as a const void pointer
we could actually template this so that
we clear it with an end or a float and
that way we could also control this
because obviously it's the data that
you're
providing here but again it's just one
of those things that i don't know how
complicated we want to make these but
those are my
thoughts regarding designing an api for
this particular function
that's kind of how i feel about it so
anyway um so let's let's actually put
this into action now so in the frame
buffer class i'm going to uh
and and you know when i design apis like
this i don't really like to
spend too long on them because i
think that it's much more beneficial for
you
for it for an engine programmer and for
probably everyone watching this series
to just actually implement the code and
then have to rewrite it
rather than spend a day planning stuff
without even knowing
what's going to happen with this because
when you're learning about game engines
and when you're learning about all this
technology that you've never done before
trying and failing is a lot more bet
it's a lot more beneficial too it's a
lot better
than scratching your head because you
you won't even you're not
you're not even going to know what to do
right you don't know what this stuff is
going to be used for in the future
because you haven't implemented a full
engine right
so instead of wasting time kind of
thinking about oh but
what if i do this or should i allow for
that or this just write the code
just write the code and then change it
it's not immutable
right it's not like this is getting
printed onto like you know
thousands of copies of like this bind of
just printed source code and that's it
it's written i can't change it it's
it's easily um changeable right you can
you can mutate this code however you
like in the future
not going to be huge you know almost
never going to be a huge deal so just
write the code and get on with your life
and get on with you know making the
actual feature work rather than
concerning yourself over the api so i
that's kind of you know that's my
opinion that's my kind of uh
rule of thumb i guess that's just what i
do so that's why i never give a thought
you know to this i mean like even
looking at some of the stuff here
because i was um
talking to the stream about this earlier
render command set clear color clear
like this this stuff is
is is like very primitive like you
probably wouldn't do something like it's
it's fine for now
but ultimately speaking frame buffers
should probably contain clear colors you
know
this is a great example of why a frame
buffer should maybe contain a clear
color because that's another thing we
could do by the way
we could specify inside frame buffer
inside the actual texture specification
we could specify a clear color for each
texture and that way when you bind a
frame buffer
it might clear it maybe you don't want
to deal with clearing inside a frame
buffer maybe that's something that a
render pass should do
right so maybe the render path should
have a clear color but then
maybe the frame buffer should have the
clear color but then the render path
should execute the clear
when the render pass when a new render
pass is started
if a clear is requested anyway this gets
very complicated
and again you know that's just a kind of
a warning to everyone who's watching
this series
this is i'm not copying this code from
an already written engine i mean i do
have hazel dev but that's not complete
either
so i'm not copying it from an already
written engine or from a textbook
so this stuff will all likely change
okay but that's kind of the beauty of it
because you get to see an engine at
different stages and you get to see the
code at different stages as well
um and you hopefully get to see the
evolution of that which i think is
really cool
all right anyway um so to do to make
this happen
uh let's just do it the way that we
initially planned which was basically a
virtual
uh void oops
virtual void um what was it clear
attachment i'm going to copy this
attachment index
um and then what do we want well that it
no surely we had no that's it
attachment index and value is really all
we care about so
const void value okay
um so again it's it's relying on the
attachment to provide you with the type
and this will only let you pro only let
you really
provide one value i guess but if it's
rgba it might be
yeah so there's there it's you could
probably add some asserts to make this a
little bit more safe
but ultimately it's um completely
reliant on the frame buffer format
and it's tied to that at the moment
which you know may or may not be a good
thing
to be honest this is not a very common
function to run so i don't think that
uh we're going to end up regretting this
too much so let's do our classic little
asset
to make sure that we're in here um and
then we need to actually obtain the
format
right so let's do this order
um spec equals
color attachment specifications add
attachment index
right so by doing this color attachments
and color attachment specifications are
always equal in size
um i think that's one of the first
things we do here um
is actually resize color attachments to
the size of color attachment
specifications so we don't need to check
both of them
um they should always be in sync in fact
but
uh basically um um
so we've got the spec now we can check
the format of the spec
right the texture format so our the
reason we even need this
is because in order to run uh so let's
get rid of this
and let's get our example code down here
so in order to actually run this code
right
we need the renderer id which again is
easy so let's let's kind of leave this
here as an example
and then we'll write our eventual line
of code here
so color attachments um let me just have
a semicolon
to get out thing back um our syntax
highlighting back so
this is just this oh right it's the same
it's just
attachment index zero is fine
now geo red integer is that format that
i'm talking about so we should be able
to get that from texture format because
texture format
is going to be set to red integer
so um how do we go from a hazel format
to an opengl format we write a function
so static gl enum
[Music]
um hazel
texture format to gl
right we pass in a texture
what was it texture format it's a
frame buffer texture format
uh fb texture format i'll do
format and then we just have a little
switch statement
um and then if i go back to here we can
basically see
what the formats are and again i
you know you don't have to implement all
of them at once but this basically ends
up being returned glrgba 8
i guess that's kind of going to be an
internal format there
frame buffer texture format
that's what it is
oh man i'll do this i might just use
this and use these for color formats
especially because it seems to be more
of like an internal format
and then i like to add a little core
research false yeah just because that's
obviously means that it's going to be an
un um an unknown format
okay so um
now that we've done this and usually i
like to align these
oops there we go rgba and red integer
so now you can see that what we should
be able to do right is
uh just do utils
i might drop this down a line at least
for now
utils uh hazel fb
texture format to gl um
spec dot texture format now this is
again
similar thing can we get a type of data
from the format
um and i think we actually have
something like this already
um or we we did something similar
we had to have right or did we not did
we just do it manually i think we did
the mail i think hazeldev has something
like this
um yeah so
or maybe not yeah how does this know
what format the data is oh it's always
unsigned by
okay
okay let's copy this
gl data type
we'll just do gl data type or gel data
yeah gel data type from format right
so we'll give this format in and then
we'll return
gl float for this but no it's it's this
is going to be unsigned bite i think
there's four of them they could both be
into though see there's one of those
situations where
you know what do you really want to
provide um
okay we'll leave it as end for now
um but you could uh there's you know
what i would probably do ultimately
because i think again
the problem is that this is actually
nothing to do with this right this is
tied with this this is basically just
saying hey what
what type are you providing because
obviously opengl is taking out a const
void pointer it could be an int
it could be a float it could be four
floats it doesn't know right
so by providing this here we're just
saying this is this is the type of data
that we're accepting
um what i was going to do is maybe imply
that the type has to be related to this
but
that gets confusing because you can
actually have multiple types based on
the internal type as well so it's not
really a good fit
so instead we could call this int and
then just say that this is a way to
clear attachment with an int
and i think that's what i'm kind of
going to do so we'll provide an int
value
here it will do that and then that way
these are always going to be the same
and you won't accidentally
ever provide a float because this
function takes an end
so i think that's what i'm going to do i
was going to make it a little bit more
arbitrary but
you know you could always add another
version of these that's float or even
template it if you want to
um but i would rather do this
and then that's kind of it i think so
let's get rid of this
we've done it um let's collapse this
onto one line because i think it's
that's pretty long line we'll make it
two um
glint and value i think that is pretty
much it
so we don't need this anymore okay
that's the function so now back in
editor layer let's see if we can clear
it
so m um let's do let's actually leave
that comment that's helpful
so m frame buffer clear attachment one
two negative one right
uh and that's it i think that should
work let's
let's take a look
all right there you go negative one so
if we now open up our
pink cube you can see we have a bunch of
50s we have a bunch of negative ones
right
everything is pretty good okay so that
is
how we clear a specific texture
attachments within frame buffers
to a particular value but i hope you
guys enjoyed this episode if you did
please don't forget to hit the like
button below next time we're going to
probably finish mouse picking honestly
or at least get a good chunk of it done
because we're going to actually make it
so that when we click or when we hover
over an entity
we're actually going to get the entity
id back and not just the number 50 so
that's going to be quite fun don't
forget you can help support the series
and my channel by going to patreon.com
there'll be a link
in the description below of this video
um you'll get access to hazeldev
and to uh all these kind of past
recorded live streams that i do where i
plan these things and it's just a
really good way to help support uh this
series and everything that's going on
in the community as well thank you guys
for all of your support i will see you
next time goodbye
[Music]
you